بينما انتظر الاعلاميون على مدخل قصر
العدل اصول حاكم مصر في لبنان الرياض
سلامه الذي حضر مكرها لجلسه استجواب حول
اتهامات طالته دخل سلام من باب خلفي بعيدا
عن عدسات كانت حاضره لرسبه
في الداخل وفد اوروبي متسلح بمئه سؤال
رفعها قاضي لبناني حفاظا على سياده الدوله
اجاب سلامي على ما طرح من اسئله في جلسه
وصفتها مصادر بالهادئه كان وصلها سلامي
بالصحبه محاميه الفرنسي نحن بانتظار
انتهاء تحيه الاوروبي بالموضوع وبعد عوده
القضاه الاوروبيين الى بلادهم بنشوف شو هو
القرار لحيت هل هيعتبر انه في جرم على
رياض شو هو هذا الجرم حجم الجرم شو هو وهل
يتم اتخاذ اجراءات بحقه وتبليغ الانتربول
واخيرا حضر سلمه اول مسؤول رفيع المستوى
يخضع للاستجواب في بلد لطالما تفلت مسؤلوه
من العقاب ومرت جرائمه الماليه والجنائيه
من دون محاسبه ومثول سلام اليوم وان كان
كشاهد هو مشهد غريب على اللبنانيين
اعتقد اللعبه وصلت الى نقطه لا رجوع فيها
رياض سلامه لا تستطيع السلطه
المنظومه ان تحميه
لان القضاء الاجنبي وضع يده ايضا على
القضيه لو تركت للقضاء المحلي
لامكن رياض سلامه ان يبقى في منصبه وان
يتابع سياسته الماليه وان يستمر في خدمه
من يحميه من اعضاء السلطه
جلساته على عجل على ان تستثمر لاحقا مع
شقيقه رجا ومساعدته مريم الحويك غنوه يتيم
العربيه